today i'm going to be meeting this girl
off a tick tock
that i ran i've never met someone off a
tic tac before
oh my god except one yeah i met him but
other than him i've never met like a
girl off a tick tock so
we're gonna try to prank him for when he
gets back and i'm i'm kind of pumped
because i don't think he's gonna be
expecting it
okay so i kind of have a headache but
i'm about to meet
this girl for the first time her name is
helena helena
okay hey guys i'm with helena we just
met
hey how do you feel it's going good so
far you're a serial killer yeah you
weren't either i
love meeting people off the internet
that's how i met my boyfriend actually
so like
i feel like what could go wrong right
worst case that
you know what could go wrong now today
we're gonna go to petsmart
and we're gonna see if we can prank one
yay so
we're gonna see if we can get a snake
and prank him
i think it's gonna go well how long have
you wanted a snake for
like a whole year a year i wanted my
birthday last year but nobody bought me
oh i'm what yes
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] okay
oh man i don't know which one is a good
one for me
what oh they're cute is there one that
you feel a connection with yes
this one she's big like me fancy
and look for beginners this is my first
name
you might want to ask the lady like what
you need
um my friend let's see
okay thank you oh man she's really
gotten up
she's really gotten up
i would suggest right off the bat first
off try to like get the other container
and try to feed them first because the
last time we fed him
i think it was a little bit earlier on
the week he should be okay but still
just enough to be on the safe side try
to feed him
and then from there after that he should
be okay okay
sounds good thank you for your help yeah
thank you
we're really getting she's really
getting it i'm gonna get a snake
this is nuts she just thought of this
today like for this prank she's like
i'll just get a snake
okay it's really getting this thing
okay guys i'm not gonna lie i felt
really sick
in that five minutes and that
however long that was i found out she's
been to jail
um she almost hit someone on the drive
um you know i'd probably hang out again
honestly i'm about to go
okay so i'm about to go to the downtown
like area here
what is it hi do you care if i have this
for my youtube channel no i don't care
but
i'll have him talking because i stutter
oh okay he can do this could you explain
to me what it is
well basically we have ethiopian coffee
okay we source ourselves we
roast it in a in a pot okay
we grind it and brew it all here and the
reason we do it this way is because you
can see
all the different colored bubbles that's
the oil still in there when you put it
through a
filtration system takes all the oil out
all you get is basically acidic water
so this is a lot smoother a lot more
flavorful
can i try it or how much do i get to
like
can i get like a cup of it or no yeah
yeah how much is it
which which one would you like to get
can i get whatever is like the sweetest
thing you have so the mauve latte
um okay a hint of rose essence it has
spices
um it's made with oat milk so it's
completely vegan but if you're not
looking for like a vegan drink you won't
even tell that
i just wanted to try something cool
honestly this looks cool super cool
so i swear that
[Music]
interesting
you guys have like a website or anything
you want to shout out um
cameroncoffee.com or follow us on
instagram because we need help
we barely have like 600 followers
we are very passionate about our craft
born in yemen he
grew up in ethiopia so this is where all
the roasting technique comes from
oh that looks fire actually it is i'm
gonna do my honest review of it
let's see
oh that's interesting
it's like good but it's like i've never
tasted anything like that before
that's so interesting honestly
all right that's stop one of the farmers
market
interesting i've never tasted anything
like that before it's like
good but i think it might be a little
too like
out there for me but
i'm gonna keep you guys coming
i didn't even think about i could play
volleyball year round in l.a
okay all right you can't even see me
this is the problem with being pale as
hell
look
is it a bold move to move here
kinda
let's see how much it costs to
paddleboard look at this look at this
there's like paddle boarding
volleyball
okay you know it's weird i feel like
all i talk about now is my boyfriend
because
everyone everywhere i go it's like it's
one year coming
what's he doing like they say it's fun
to like
date someone famous but
i feel like i don't exist sometimes i'm
like
i'm gonna be there i'm pretty cool but
whatever
it's cool it's cool
i'm not mad just disappointed
you ever start walking and like know
you made a mistake
um so it's like 80 degrees
in california i'm in a black t-shirt
and blue jeans why
why god i know my parents house is like
nice and i know my parents you know they
do
they do pretty well for themselves but
i'm cheap as hell
i won't even pay for the uber when i
could just walk
like a mile i mean a mile sometimes i'll
walk i'll i'll get new
but not usually i hate i literally hate
spending money and
i don't fit in here i could go do like
touristy [ __ ] in l.a but like
one everything's closed and then on top
of that like
okay so now guys i'm going to visit
my cousin jonathan we're gonna go get
ice cream jonathan's really cool because
jonathan literally made all of uber's
commercials for like
10 years so if you need like commercial
stuff you should talk to him
but i'm gonna ask him what he thinks
about me moving to la because it's kind
of crazy
kind of wild maybe i should do
what do i do it what if i do it that's
crazy i don't see a downside but
other than the fact my parents are going
to kill me but
you can't win them all honestly this is
the one i was telling you about
he made uber's commercials for like 10
years
right uh it wasn't that long but yeah
okay
yeah like a long time and is this the
ice cream
shop where so do you want to tell us
where we're at so we're in venice
um venice is a more
hip hipster place of uh
southern california if we're gonna show
up oh it's over here
and then salt and straw where we are i
believe it started in portland
don't quote me on that but it's an ice
cream place
and then they've started expanding into
southern california there's also one up
in palo alto which is in northern
california
um but yeah i know venice this is avid
kenny this is like the main
rag of this part of town
there's a lot of really good restaurants
i believe
a couple restaurants that have been
featured there's a couple restaurants
around here that have been featured on
chef's table so it's beautiful it's a
balmy 75 degrees so
should be should be a great time for ice
cream and how do you feel
about how a skill one to ten how bad of
an idea would it be to me to come here
zero i think uh i think you should
follow your
you should follow your income
all right it looks like i'm coming to la
guys i never thought i'd be an l.a girl
2020 has been a weird year all right
guys i got
a salted caramel chocolate chip
with cookie dough i said she could
surprise me on the second one so let's
see what she gets me
i don't know i trust her though
i feel like i feel like it's going to be
good
so she picked honey lavender we're gonna
see if i like it
all right record your reaction eat it
record my reaction yeah yeah say it say
if you like it
i mean i know i like it i've had this
before i like it it's a i'm a fan
although i'm not a fan of this i wish
they actually had like you know
proper cones and stuff what did you get
again so there's cold brew on the top
and then salted mocha some kind of
cookie dough [ __ ] at the bottom
you just gotta i just want to see if i
like it it doesn't have to be anything
fancy
all right this is the one that she
picked out for me this is
lavender okay that's fire
that's really good that's good i
recommend
i recommend this place